not divided
that's a 12 foot tall snow sculpture and
we did that in breckenridge colorado so
here is a mobius band that makes
three twists okay by itself
you know we don't care about the shape
the mobius pad by itself is really no
different to a mathematician than the
rubber band it's just a loop okay we're
not looking at the cross section and
whether it's twisted or not it's just
we're looking at the center line of the
knot that defines the knot but once you
take the mobius pan and you split it
down the middle it becomes a knot now
it happens to be a trefoil knot
because now if you have these strands
being nice and soft you can move them
around and they would be interlinked in
exactly the same way as this copper
structure if it's only singly twisted it
will simply open up in a loop that's
twice the size and actually has a full
twist in it so it depends on how much
twist it is if the mobius band is even
more twisted like five times you may get
this other knob that we had labeled as
five sub one or something like that
which you know gives an ever more
coiling of that same thing we started
out with a trefoil knot now
and so
here
is
roughly
a trefoil dot okay
and then we split this trefoil knot down
the middle because it happens
in this trifold knot
to be off a mobius structure so let me
back up a little bit and show you two
different trefoils they're two artistic
trefoil knots i kind of
call them like you know trefoil standing
on its own two feet because they were
carefully designed so that you know i
can actually so stand them up they're
not gonna topple over
can you see a difference well i'm
claiming one of them is a mobius band
and the other one is not let's figure
out you know um whether this one is
twisted so i'm starting on the side
towards the camera up on the lobe here
and i'm running my finger slowly down
here
i get to the underside of this
foot i'm coming to the front here
i'm getting around i'm staying here on
the upper side of that foot i'm coming
up here and i'm back to where i started
on the same side so this one is
double-sided okay i could paint the side
green and i could paint the other one
red and everything would be fine but now
let's compare that to the other mobius
band if i'm starting here again on your
side
i'm moving down here i'm getting to the
bottom of this foot
i'm on the bottom of this highly curved
little thingy i'm going to the middle
staying at the bottom here staying at
the bottom side coming around being at
the bottom of this foot now i'm coming
up the back side and so basically i'm
coming off to the back side and i've
gotten to the other side
if i continue again sliding down here
being on the upper side sliding over on
the upper side here coming back and i'm
coming back to where i started but i had
to go around the loop twice
and in that process i would have painted
everything green right and there's no
way i can paint one or the other side
without the two colors running into one
other at some point this is the idea of
a mobius
trefoil knot and then we took a slightly
different shape of again you can see
this looks roughly like a
trefoil knot
except it started out with a cross
section that was more or less you know
rectangular originally but then we
carved out the middle part to make
essentially a split and because it's a
mobius band when i do this
i get a knot that is not really divided
that's why we call it not divided it's
like a roller coaster where if you start
on this side of the big lobe and you go
around the whole roller coaster by the
time you come the first time back up on
the mountain you're actually are on the
other side and then you have to go once
through more through the roller coaster
until you come back to where you started
so it's just one long string you know
essentially tied together and while when
it was still fused without the gap in
the middle it was a trifold knot now
it's a much more complicated knot how
many crossings does this thing have
actually not that easy to see but i was
amazed at msri you know it's like a
seven-year-old kit and i showed them
that and within seconds he said 12. and
he realized wherever we had a crossing
in our trifold knot we now had split it
we now get four crossings
we have this situation
and so indeed he's right you know now we
have three times four crossings it's a
twelve crossing knot so by the time
you're kind of looking through the knot
table you're already you know very far
down there where there's thousands of
different knots right and that's just
one of them
our roller coasters knots i'm pretty
sure that some of them are because i
mean that makes kind of fun you know you
wanna
many of them has of these like figure
eight configuration that go sometimes
around the loop and then they go through
the figure eight by the time you go a
couple of times through the middle with
figure eight
it is very likely that the things are
not that
but
you can never be quite sure there's some
very complicated looking knots that you
can find on the internet like when you
look for something like difficult i'm
not or difficult trivial not they show
you not that you swear this is a real
not
but actually it's not
experimental part of dna topology so the
field is called dna topology we study
geometry and topology of circular dna
molecules or linear dna molecules that
locally behave as circles same with this
one except it goes back so starts the
front curls back hold it on the way down
now you're going to take this lace put
it under that loop